[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a starting revelation in alec baldwin's
first interview since the deadly rush
shooting well the trigger wasn't pulled
i didn't pull the trigger so you never
pulled the trigger no no no no no i
would never point a gun at anyone and
pull a trigger at them never and the
federal trial of elaine maxwell experts
break down the logistics of the
socialite's alleged sexual grooming a
new hampshire man on trial for the
murder of his wife but could the latest
witness scrap the defense's claim of
suicide based on your many interactions
with your sister did she ever appear
suicidal no
and later the schools did have
contact with the student the day before
and the day of the shooting for behavior
in the classroom that they felt was
concerning the shocking moments leading
up to the deadly school shooting in
oxford michigan law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin actor alec baldwin speaks
extensively for the first time about the
shooting on the set of russ that killed
cinematographer helena hutchins
law and crime's angel levy is here with
baldwin's surprising comments
brian alec baldwin spoke with abc news
and he claims that he didn't pull the
trigger on the gun that killed helena
hutchins this this interview came
shortly after the release of a new
search warrant for pdq arms and prop in
new mexico the affidavit for that
warrant says the company provided the
firearms and ammunition for the set of
rust hutchins was killed in october when
baldwin was practicing a cross draw on
the film set
since then questions have been raised
about how live ammo made it onto the set
and the film's armor hannah gutierrez
reed and assistant director dave halls
who handed the gun to baldwin that day
this is part of what alec baldwin told
abc news
it wasn't in the script for the trigger
to be pulled well the trigger wasn't
pulled i didn't pull the trigger so you
never pulled the trigger no no no no i
would never point a gun at anyone to
pull a trigger at them never
now baldwin started to cry as he said
that everyone loved and admired helena
hutchins meanwhile attorney attorneys
for gutierrez reid the film's armorer
say the sheriff's office has taken a
huge step in unearthing the truth by
executing a search warrant at pdq arm
and prop an attorney for that prop shop
and the shop's owner says that he has
been cooperating since the beginning of
this investigation
brian
thanks angeannette joining us today is
civil rights attorney katie smith and
terry austin katie hutchins family must
be listening intensely to these
statements made by alec baldwin do you
see anything that affects baldwin in
terms of a civil lawsuit
absolutely brian i mean guns don't go
off by themselves right this should
never have happened it's a travesty and
there is some way to apportion the fault
and the blame from either a criminal
perspective or from a civil perspective
just because he didn't pull the trigger
does not mean he didn't somehow
unlawfully or
recklessly handle that weapon or
it had to have discharged by some sort
of malfunction so these are things that
by examining the weapon they will be
able to determine with some specificity
in a forensic way all right so terry
that's the civil side and that's a lower
standard so let's look at a higher
standard and criminal
perspective so what alec baldwin say
absolve him of all guilt or is there
still a possibility he could face
criminal charges
there is still that possibility brian
that he could face criminal charges the
d.a actually said they're not ruling out
criminal charges for anyone it's
everything on the table and regardless
of what alex states in an interview he
is still the person holding the gun one
thing i am curious about is why he
didn't mention this
immediately after the event occurred
because now he's saying it you know
weeks later so it doesn't really make a
lot of sense it sounds like this is just
something that his lawyers have told him
to say so i think he could possibly face
some criminal liability and certainly
the assistant director who said cold gun
meaning safe could face criminal
liability as well absolutely still a
liability for a lot of people on that
set and jeannette back to baldwin's
claim that he didn't pull the trigger on
the revolver is that possible
i spoke with two firearms experts and
one of them i actually interviewed here
on the law and crime network and he said
that's not really possible he said it's
possible that he had his finger on the
trigger but didn't actually
feel that he pulled it and maybe that
you know he actually did
pull it without pulling it back a lot
and he feels he didn't pull the trigger
but he thinks it's basically impossible
and also dave halls that assistant
director i should mention he actually is
backing up that claim his attorney is in
that abc news special and says that
halls has said from day one that baldwin
didn't pull the trigger so it'll be
interesting to see what comes out of
this absolutely a lot of forensics both
in terms of dna or fingerprints perhaps
and also the operation of that weapon
but we'll
absolutely give you updates as we
continue
moving on to minnesota a jury selections
continues for ex-cop kim potter eleven
jurors are seated so far five men and
six women eight jurors are white two are
asian and one is black in all there will
be 12 jurors with two alternates potter
is charged with manslaughter in the
shooting death of dante wright it
happened during a traffic stop just
outside minneapolis and brooklyn center
in april police were pulling right over
for an expired tag when they determined
he had an outstanding warrant as they
attempted to take him into custody body
camera videos showed him resisting
potter warns right he's going to tase
him but instead of pulling her out her
taser she pulled out her gun and shot
right in the chest the former cops
defense argues the shooting was an
accident when the full jury is seated
the trial will begin on december 8th law
and crime will bring you full coverage
from the courtroom
more controversy from the family behind
a hit netflix show tiger king
the daughter of central figure bhagavan
doc antler is arrested in connection to
a shooting in
myrtle beach south carolina tawny sky
anthel is charged with unlawfully
possessing a pistol after police found a
weapon in the vehicle she was riding in
officials say the vehicle matched a
description of one linked to a shooting
over the weekend the driver 30 year old
derrick frost allegedly had a glock
visible in the side door stored without
a concealed weapons permit both were
booked and later released on personal
recognizance bonds antle also faces
separate charges relating to her father
doc antle's animal trafficking charges
antles was featured on the documentary
tiger king alongside breakout star joe
exotic as long crime daily reported last
week exotic is now being treated for
prostate cancer at a federal medical
center he is serving out a sentence on a
murder murder-for-hire conviction
stemming from a plot to kill wildlife
activist carol baskin
still ahead on law and crime daily a new
hampshire man faces life in prison for
the murder of his wife but could her
death have been a suicide
but first the federal trial of gillane
maxwell continues in new york as a
former epstein employee takes the stand
the major takeaways from the testimony
next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily our
coverage continues now in the federal
trial of gillane maxwell the one-time
socialite and companion of jeffrey
epstein on thursday a former epstein
employee testified he saw many topless
women at the disgraced financiers at
state
fifty-nine-year-old maxwell is charged
with multiple sex trafficking crimes for
allegedly helping epstein groom girls as
young as 14 for sexual abuse federal
prosecutors say maxwell sometimes
participated in illegal sex acts on
thursday the prosecution called juan
alessi the housekeeper for absentee's
palm beach estate from 1990 to 2002.
unless he described maxwell as the quote
lady of the house and said epstein
didn't like to be looked at in the eyes
he also told jurors he saw many women at
epstein's pool often going topless ahead
of his testimony the prosecution called
an expert witness to testify about
grooming behaviors in child sex abuse
cases maxwell's defense team maintains
she is a scapegoat for jeffrey epstein
she has pled not guilty to all charges
two years ago epstein was found dead by
suicide just months after his arrest on
federal charges of sex trafficking
let's bring back civil rights attorney
katie smith and terry austin terry we've
seen testimony about grooming minors
before like in the r kelly trial so how
does this expert's testimony tie in with
the first alleged victim jane
brian this expert's testimony tied in
perfectly to what jane was saying the
expert was a psychologist and she was
basically talking about interpersonal
violence and traumatic stress and what
she said about grooming is that the
abuser selects their victims and they
use lies and deception and manipulation
to set that stage for abuse and they try
to normalize sexual activity and jane
testified exactly to that she said that
maxwell walked up to her had a cute
little dog and basically after that
epstein walked up and asked jane for her
phone number and eventually they took
her and they
you know abused her so it just matched
perfectly with what the expert was
saying so that is about this alleged
victim's own uh experiences and how it
connects with what the expert is saying
katie on the other side in the afternoon
of day four juan alessi who ran
epstein's home testified what's the
prosecution really getting at about the
environment of topless women and things
going around in epstein's home
that's the thing brian you don't want to
tread into territory that winds up being
excluded because it is more prejudicial
than it is probative but the problem
here because we have this missing seat
of epstein that we need to establish
first that there was illegal activity
going on there and a culture that
fostered that in addition to the
grooming behaviors and second that she
participated in it so we're gonna have a
wide swath of information that's going
to be coming in to really paint the true
den of depravity that was that resonance
denim to property i think that's the
term that the prosecution's probably
going to want to uh hitch their wagon to
come summation so that makes a lot of
sense thank you both switching coasts
now to federal court in california where
former therons ceo elizabeth holmes
faces cross-examination while on the
stand
now 11 weeks into the trial prosecutors
hit homes hard in her days-long
testimony questioning her extensively
about a relationship with former ceo
ramesh sunni bhawani holmes defense team
claimed she was romantically involved
with bohani in what lawyers describe as
a quote abusive partner relationship
part of holmes defense also puts blame
on theranos's employees as a former ceo
testified she was told progress was on
track at the startup but prosecutors
grilled holmes in the cross-examination
suggesting she knew her company couldn't
fulfill promises they argued holmes
tried to silence whistleblowers and
attempted to kill an investigative
report exposing theranos's flawed
technology the silicon valley lab was
touted as a breakthrough blood testing
company claiming to be faster and
cheaper than traditional blood testing
later tests found many issues with
holmes edison device holm's testimony
expected to be heavy as the jury decides
whether to convict her on criminal fraud
which could lead to decades behind bars
holmes cross examination resumes next
week
coming up on law and crime daily a 15
year old school shooter will be tried as
an adult what rare charges he now faces
following tuesday's deadly shooting in
michigan plus witness testimony
continues in new hampshire versus
william argy the jury hears from those
close to both the defendant and the
victim
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
new hampshire man faces life in prison
for the murder of his wife he says she
committed suicide but testimony from her
brother says otherwise prosecutors say
46-year-old william bill argy killed his
wife maureen back in 2019 they say he
strangled or suffocated her after that
they say he attempted suicide ran off
and gambled at a casino argy's defense
maintains his wife committed suicide and
that he found her in the bed with a
sheet around her neck at the time of her
death argy faced a gambling addiction
mounting debt and job loss he was also
the sole beneficiary of his wife's four
hundred thousand dollar life insurance
policy on thursday maureen argy's
brother took the stand testifying he
spoke to his sister often before her
death
without seeing any red flags
based on your many interactions with
your sister did she ever appear suicidal
no
were you and your family supportive of
her plans to move out and to proceed
with the divorce of her husband
yes
and when you spoke with maureen about
these plans
what was her tone of voice and her
demeanor like during these conversations
maureen wanted to go through with the
divorce but she was worried about how it
would impact her children
that was her main primary focus she
didn't want
the children to have to go through it
and for the children to be affected by
it in any way and that was
one of the reasons that was her reason
for staying and trying to make it work
constantly
a friend of bill argy also took the
stand testifying he spoke to the
defendant just days before his wife's
death
he was not doing good he was in a bad
place
he was very angry
and sad
at the same time
do you recall him saying anything about
his job status
at that time i do recall him saying he
didn't have a job
what do you recall him saying about the
status of his marriage
that it was crumbling
that maureen
was asking for a divorce
do you recall him discussing bankruptcy
i do and what did he say about that that
the house is being repossessed
that they
they don't have anything
here to discuss the latest in the new
hampshire murder trial for insurance is
civil rights attorney katie smith and
co-host terry austin terry maureen the
victim in this case obviously can't take
the stand but to what her brother say
bring the trial a little bit closer to
her prosecution on her behalf
actually maureen's brother matthew was
an excellent witness he served two
purposes first of all they wanted to
bring her to life and he talked about
the fact that she was soft-spoken she
was a great mom she was caring for other
people and then they also wanted to
establish that she never wanted to
commit suicide and they did that by
showing the emails prior to her death
she was coordinating the fact that she
was making a move and the move was
scheduled for april 6th and 7th so she
basically was trying to live and moving
forward with her life
now on the other side katie how
incriminating are argie's friend's words
uh in testifying about his kind of
mentality before the death does this
almost mean that rg has to testify to
try to explain this away
i mean brian it's not good i mean of
course one of the things that the
prosecution always wants to show but
it's not required is motive and there's
so much motive here i mean there's 400
000 some motivating factors with the
money we know that he was in a desperate
place and his friends really paint him
in that exact spot so it's problematic i
think the best thing the defense has is
to really show that this was not a
homicide and it was a suicide but that
again is also a very uphill battle
absolutely uphill battle for william rg
indeed it's going to be interesting with
all of the circumstantial evidence all
of this mode of what the defense can do
because right now seems like a very
strong case for the prosecution
when we come back what we know so far
about the 15 year old suspect in the
michigan high school shooting what led
up to the deadly attack and what charges
he now faces more on the investigation
next
welcome back to law and crime daily
investigators say the 15-year-old boy
responsible for the deadly school
shooting in michigan met with school
officials just hours before a shooting
about concerning behavior
on wednesday prosecutors announced ethan
crumbly will be charged as an adult on
multiple accounts including terrorism
causing death first degree murder and
assault with intent to murder this comes
after tuesday's deadly shooting in
oxford michigan where officials say
crumbly shot and killed four people
seven more were wounded prosecutors say
he methodically and deliberately shot at
students and teachers firing 30 rounds
during a 5-minute period officials later
found cell phone video and a journal
entries detailing his plans to kill
fellow classmates on wednesday crumbly
was arraigned in oakland county he
refused to speak during his appearance
but pled not guilty through his attorney
right now authorities are still working
to determine why the suspect planned the
attack
any updates on a motive just yet sure
no
we obviously are not communicating with
the suspect so we can't get that from
him we're working you know items that we
have seized as i talked about documents
papers phones evidentiary value items to
look to see if there's something that
would lead to
us understanding what motivate him but i
will say again there is nothing
that he could have
faced that would warrant
senseless
absolutely brutal violence on other kids
and i have also asked the school if they
had any records of him being bullied and
the coordinator of anti-bullying
programs
had no information that he'd been
bullied by anyone
katie journals and cell phone video how
will that affect uh this criminal case
against ethan crumbly
it's not good i mean the worst words
that could be used against you are your
own and having some sort of written
documentation of your motive that
actually coincides with the acts that
you took are extremely damaging and i'm
certain that they would be admissible
and relevant if they really did mirror
what actually occurred
now terry the video that has gone out of
the
students inside the michigan school
hearing that knock and hearing someone
say come out and check my badge bro we
found out that's an actual sheriff but
one thing that i think should be
applauded and is also a little
heartbreaking is the quick thinking of
those students to recognize a word such
as bro which i was bizarre to me that an
officer is using that word and then
react in the way that they did what was
your reaction to the offers to the
students sorry quick thinking well you
know it is a good thing that it turned
out to actually be the officer who was
trying to get in but you also have to
applaud those students it was brilliant
of them to be thinking about the fact
that the shooter could
have been trying to disguise himself as
a police officer and so they would not
open that door unless they were 100 sure
the reason that it's heartbreaking is
because our students today have to be
trained on how to avoid these types of
situations how to get out of these types
of situations and these students were
thinking very quickly on their feet they
went in the room they hid they you know
bundled together and then when they had
some doubt as to whether or not this was
a shooter or whether it was a police
officer they aired on the side of
caution and they fled and they fled into
the arms of real police officers and
again of course that was a real police
officer but good thinking on their part
absolutely and thank you very much katie
as well as terry and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you